- I heard in Georgia
that you have something
called Kool-Aid pickles.
- Yeah.
- I love pickles.
- Okay. So our aunt,
she's from Mississippi
and she makes Kool-Aid pickles.
It's like pickles that
sit in Kool-Aid overnight
and at first I was like,
Um, I'm not so sure,
but when I had them I was like, wow.
- They are the best thing ever.
You should really try them.
- Kool-Aid pickles are really good.
I mean, I don't know how to explain it,
but you have to try it to get it.
- Well, we heard about
your Kool-Aid pickles
and I love pickles.
So I was like, I'm down to try.
So Justin, I think you
have some Kool-Aid pickles.
Is that what we have here?
Okay. Okay. I'm gonna try Kool-Aid pickle.
- Okay.
- Okay. My mouth is watering.
- And there's different flavors.
- You know what? It's a
sweet. It's a sweet and sour.
- Yep.
- You know let me just try again.
- Let me just make sure I'm getting it.
- My mouth is gonna be purple or pink.
- Got that. Red one.
- I did. That was my first one.
Oh, that was great.
- So good.
- It's just a great pickle.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. It's the sweet and salty.
- Yes.
- That's fabulous.
What's your aunt's name?
- Her name is La'Kendra.
- La'Kendra? Oh, La'Kendra.
You make some great pickles.